24 hours ago Google Deep Mind released
Alpha geometry and while their leaders
are calling it a step toward AGI the
team itself is warning everyone not to
overhype it I've read the paper in
nature the press releases and Associated
interviews and feel that hitting gold
for geometry in the international math
Olympiad is significant more so for what
it signifies about the growing alliance
between language models and search idea
generation and brute for for in that
same vein we'll also take a quick peek
at Alpha codium the brand new OP sourced
rival to Alpha code from Google deepmind
but let's start all the way down in the
day-to-day way AI is now being used for
math education if you think this is the
way to go to get kids interested let me
know it's bordered off by these two
values so in this case the integral
would be the area of this shape here
what about this other stuff here let me
take it from here Kim that tall swirly
symbol on the left is an S which stands
for sum what are we summing we're
summing the area of these strips a tiny
distance DX multiplied by the height
which is the value of the function but
these are way too thick Taylor DX is
actually really really tiny for those
who don't know the international math
Olympiad is the most prestigious math
competition in the world I remember
competing in challenges just to get into
the international math Olympiad spoiler
I didn't get in but I would say I never
studied that hard anyway this new system
Alpha geometry scores almost as highly
as the average IMO gold medalist but
specifically for a subset of geometry
problems only not algebra or number
Theory we're talking just geometry so
it's not like Alpha geometry did an IMO
test it just did 30 geometry IMO
questions nevertheless getting a gold
medal overall in the IMO has long been
one of the Holy Grails of machine
learning that's maybe why one of the
co-founders of Deep Mind said AGI keeps
getting closer and even Demis cabis the
leader of Deep Mind and one of the other
co-founders said this congrats to the
team this represents another step on the
road to AGI he later edited out that
last sentence possibly because he read
that the team said not to overhype it
but also he might have read some of the
caveats in the paper itself of course
I'll get to the paper but first I want
to set the stage there is now a grand
prize of five million and an overall
prize pool of 10 million for getting
gold in the IMO 2 years ago the forecast
on metaculus for an AI getting a gold
medal was 2037 and what is it as of
tonight 2027 and of course you don't
need me to tell you that's just 3 and
1/2 years away so how does it work well
Alpha geometry is a neuros symbolic
system a combination of a neural network
and the old-fashioned symbolic
pre-programmed systems and in fact that
Alliance between large language models
noral networks and old-fashioned
pre-programmed systems is going to be
the theme of this video idea generation
and you could call it creativity plus
brute force and search that Alliance I
predict in the future will yield AGI
here is a simple example of how it works
imagine you're trying to prove that two
angles are equal in an Isles triangle a
key part of that proof is to drop a
perpendicular line down from a to hit
the midpoint of B and C the thing is
symbolic systems aren't designed to
propose those kind of constructs idea
generation isn't their Forte that's
where a language model came in the
language model in this case was only 151
million parameters and it was trained on
Purely synthetic data the purely
synthetic training data was all about
getting the model to provide proofs for
various geometric statements in 91
million of those samples brute force
would be enough just step-by-step
deduction using known rules rules but in
9 million cases you would need one of
these constructs the authors call them
pulling rabbits out of the hat and the
language model was ftuned on those
examples it paid particular attention to
those examples basically it got really
good at suggesting such constructs going
back to this example the moment you
posit that line an old-fashioned
symbolic deducer could then solve the
rest it could mechanically produce the
proof that these two angles are equal
basically the angle at B and the angle
at C if by the way the deducer couldn't
solve the problem it would send it back
to the language model to suggest other
constructs While most of that training
data involved basic proofs Apparently
one involved two constructs and a proof
length of
247 deduction steps I can start to see
why Alpha geometry outperformed all but
the best humans a bit below somewhat
sheepishly the authors admit that these
Solutions tend not to be symmetrical
like human discovered theorems as they
are not biased towards any aesthetic
standard as in these Solutions don't
look good they look like trash but they
work the lead author of the paper put
this really well in a video on his own
YouTube channel and pointed out that the
approach isn't fully novel The General
observation here is that given a hard
problem we usually have to come up with
one or more rabbits in order to
transform the problem into a more
mechanical state in such a way that the
symbolic engine or the mechanical solver
can just take the problem and then solve
it but if the solver failed to solve the
problem then we can always come back and
ask for more rabit and then we keep
doing this in a loop until we find the
solution and so with this observation
our Sol here pretty much reflect the
structure of this observation where we
built a neural language model that is
trained to propose magic instruction and
then we built a symbolic engine that is
tasked with handling all the mechanical
cases and the mechanical deduction in
geometry and then we put these two
components into a loop so that we obtain
a neural symbolic server named a
geometry let me point to an important
fact that is the observation of neuros
symbolic structure is not a novel
observation that is made in our work in
fact in 2020 Po and SG have already
pointed out that a major limitation of
the improving compared to human is in
fact the ability to generate original
mathematical terms and this limitation
might be addressable via the generation
from language models geometry it seems
might be particularly amable to this
approach as one IMO gold medalist and
Fields medalist put it finding solutions
for IMO geometry problems Works a little
bit like chess in the sense that we have
a rather small number of sensible moves
at each step nevertheless he says he was
stunned that they could make it work
they even cheeky compare their system
trained on 100 million proofs with GPT 4
it apparently had a success rate of 0%
often making syntactic and semantic
errors of course deciding which of the
many constructs to use is a question of
search and comp compute budget but they
noticed that using less than 2% of that
search budget analyzing eight constructs
each time versus 512 during test time it
could still solve 21 problems that would
still put it at just below the silver
medalist level and way above the
previous state-of-the-art speaking of
search and compute budget though I
couldn't help but notice this they use
nvidia's v00 gpus and said somewhat
modestly scaling up these factors to
examine a larger fraction of the search
space might improve Alpha geometry
results even further I think frankly
that's an understatement because the
V100 was replaced in 2020 with the a100
recently replaced by the h100 and yes I
know I pronounce my H's in a cogni way
even the h100 from Nvidia is going to be
replaced this year with the B100 and
next year with the X100 I've almost lost
count now of how many generations behind
the V100 is so the fact that they use
v100s is incredibly impressive I feel
like the bitter lesson is going to
strike again soon and Imo geometry is
going to be all but solved by next year
I must caution though that this had been
foreseen including by Paul Cristiano
former head of alignment at open Ai and
Imo participant when he was younger he
predicted that AI would soon solve most
geometry problems essentially for free
Deep Mind in their blog post go a bit
further though they describe this as
demonstrating ai's growing ability to
reason logically and to discover and
verify new knowledge I feel like there
might be years more of debate over
whether it's appropriate to use that
word reason for what's happening here
but in the end it might end up being
semantics nevertheless Google are open
sourcing the alpha geometry code and
model within a year they hope it will be
inside Google's Gemini remember Google
also promised that that Alpha code too
would be put inside Gemini so that's a
lot of Alphas to go around of course
many of you might be wondering if this
is an example of mathematics falling
first which which would then lead to a
torrent of results that will impact
everything in theoretical science as one
machine learning Professor put it well
we simply don't know as the co-founder
of xai and former googler put it it
leaves a lot of questions open he said
it's not easily generalizable to other
domains and other areas of math that's
not going to stop the lead author
attempting to generalize the system
across mathematical fields and Beyond
but speaking of alpha code and open
sourcing we now have Alpha codium it's
open source single click and is claimed
to beat Alpha code 2 without fine-tuning
all the relevant links will be in the
description but there's another reason
why I bring it up in this video not just
that it's brand new and state-of-the-art
but it's also that same theme of llms
proposing Solutions and iterating based
on feedback from the environment in this
case code unit tests as Andre karpathy
puts it we are moving away from that
naive prompt to Auto regressive token by
token can answer where llms like gp4 are
forced to put out Immediate Solutions
it's becoming more like a conversation
between llms and their environment in my
own tests for smart GPT 2.0 I'm
discovering the same thing as the
authors when they say this try to avoid
direct questions and leave room for
exploration well the way I would
translate that is that if you force an
llm into an immediate answer it will
then pick an answer and then stick to it
it values fluency over accuracy so
what's the answer try to avoid those
direct questions encourage reflection
that's probably why Chain of Thought
works so well here's a great summary
from Santiago on Twitter First Alpha
codium gets the llm and its model
agnostic to reason about the problem
describe it using bullet points and
focus on the goal inputs outputs rules
Etc then make the model reason about the
tests it would need generate potential
Solutions and rank them in order of
correctness Simplicity and robustness
now generate more diverse tests for edge
cases and here's the key step pick a
solution generate the code and run it on
a few test cases if the test fail
improve the code and repeat the process
I can't help but notice that this is
eerily reminiscent of some of the prep
work I did for smart GPT I won't go
through it now but what it involved was
commanding the model to not output a
solution immediately in fact I wanted it
to generate mistakes that students might
make then I would force it to come up
with test cases and the rest of the
steps I might cover in another video but
it was that same approach the same idea
don't get the model to Output an
immediate answer delay that as long as
possible and first generate test cases
it's almost like you're forcing it to
reason logically and yes in case you're
wondering this works amazingly for
mathematics here are some of the results
of alpha codium compared to direct
prompting across a range of models so
you might mention this video to anyone
who thinks llms have peaked the theme of
using them for idea generation and then
external experimentation just keeps
occurring again and again in the
literature we saw it with Eureka and if
you haven't seen my video on that do
check it out the llm gpc4 would propose
reward functions and these would be
tested in a simulated environment and
the reflection fed back in and even the
notorious llm skeptic Professor Ralph
who I interviewed for AI insiders
updated in November his original paper
on the planning abilities of llms
tweaking the ending to say this we
demonstrate that llm generated plans can
improve the search process for
underlying sound planners and
additionally show that external verifies
can help provide feedback on the
generated plans and back prompt the llm
for better Plan Generation coming from
him that's borderline euphoric and yes I
can't help but mention that I go into
more detail on this topic on AI Insiders
on patreon the link is in the
description and that's not just for this
video on its implications for embodiment
and Robotics I also interview Professor
Ral for this video on reasoning as the
holy grail for artificial intelligence
while we're here though I can't resist
mentioning that I also released this
video tonight on AI insiders basically
it's my attempt through analyzing five
papers to answer the question as to
whether llms boost worker productivity
and no unfortunately the ad is not yet
over because today I also released this
video from Donato capitella he's an AI
Insider himself and one of the benefits
is that members can submit explainers
for other insiders to watch the best of
these I'll talk about on the main
Channel which is what I'm doing right
now this was a fantastic video from
Donato who is a cyber security
consultant based in London in fact I
fairly recently met up with him again
proving that I am not GPT 5 I'm even
going to go one step further and
recommend his YouTube channel I think it
is criminally underrated he creates
partly with AI admittedly these amazing
detailed diagrams to explain certain
topics if you want to know what I mean
check out his channel so no in summary
llms are not peing but here's another
quick example just 48 hours ago we heard
about Google laying off a thousand
workers but what about their workers at
Google Deep Mind no those workers they
are spending hundreds of thousands to
millions of dollars to keep them at
Google that's because openai has hired
at least six of Google's Gemini
contributors since October indeed
MoneyWise I would say things are heating
up rather than slowing down I imagine
Samsung have signed a multibillion
dollar contract to get access to Google
Gemini models in their smartphones and
apparently Samsung will be among the
first Partners to test Gemini Ultra so
no Alpha geometry and Alpha codium are
definitely not AGI but neither is the
race 2 AGI slowing down anytime soon
thank you so much for watching and have
a wonderful day